oh welcome to me speaking hello
and welcome to the new world review
where today we're stepping away from the
protagonists
no the other protagonists and the
protagonists yes those ones this time
to see how some other people across the
world are faring in this strange
insectoid phenomenon there's some ground
to cover with this so let's get into
episodes 96 and 97.
we left the primary storyline alone this
episode to return to some characters we
haven't seen for a while and to see some
characters we haven't seen before
now either the phantom troop were just
toying around in the last arc
or they've really stepped up their game
because some of the abilities
all of them actually were pretty new and
they were all using conditions to engage
see i pay attention sometimes to what's
happening mechanically
the ants are really spreading out and
taking over the world and
having something like that happen is
really problematic because from a
narrative perspective
this is clearly going to have to be
realistically
the last arc no matter what like even if
takashi could keep going
or did keep going or kept going forever
this would be the last arc there's no
way
barring a deus ex machina situation
where they reset the world or something
that all the ants can be killed or
deactivated there are too many of them
and they've gone too far
even so far as to take over a city that
is literally
and figuratively a dump which makes
sense actually i can imagine bugs really
enjoying a dump
bugs do that what i really enjoy about
how tagashi has portrayed the characters
is that they've all somehow managed to
inherit pride that flows consistently
through the species
almost like humanity arguably the only
one this doesn't apply to is cult but
then there is pride in his belief that
he can take care of his family and the
pride that he could protect his mother
and how and now
he has to protect the teeny teeny baby
that he has to look after like that
that's
i suppose maybe he is pride he is
pride and actually thinking about it she
might become the deus ex
so i guess it's a watch this space if
the show ever gets that far
i'm very aware that no new episodes or
manga has actually been written in the
time i've been recording these reviews
so the closer i get to the end of the
playlist
the more i'm seeing reasons why one
might stop beyond physical
ill health takashi is known to me anyway
for not being able to wrap arcs up
cleanly and that wouldn't really matter
but this one isn't just sprawled across
a city
it's an uncontained biohazard that's
uncontainable by all but an elite number
of people
all of whom oddly exhibit the same pride
as the primary ants and may or may not
choose to
actually bother to engage if the
situation seems at all boring
it's almost like the only people who
want to be hunters
are the people who are bored by the rest
of society
or think themselves better than the rest
of society kel
surprise there were some lovely moments
in this episode
most of which were about culture and how
abilities develop i'm also a little
confused by
one of the people it pertains to but
let's talk about our holy man first
holy holy holy he's whole
whole he's full of holes i don't
honestly know his name because we
learned about his culture first and i
got so enthralled that i only remember
that he's from the bapu
which is something i repeatedly said to
liam when he asked which episode i just
watched it was the bapu guy
yes the bapu guy liam then said a name
which i don't remember and i said yes he
is bapu i'm a huge fan of cultural
development and understanding the
history of nobility and why it exists is
such a wonderful deviation from
tagashi's usual method of doing things
today we've only really gone into the
socio-cultural backgrounds of those who
we consider villains and while i
consider the phantom
troop to be villains they're sort of
anti-villains cause we have a lot of
appreciation for their relationship with
each other and the way that they see the
world
we like them which is i mean you can
dislike a villain but still
we learned about the entire cultural
history of this guy's ability before we
engaged with him and so everything that
happened afterward the sound design the
combination with classical music to give
us westerners a grounding connection to
appreciate it from
it all became more cohesive as a result
and i'm not saying every character must
have that development but what i'm
saying
is that if every character did have that
development hunter hunter would be a
hundred times better than it is
which is saying something for an already
well-loved anime
though the character then threw a planet
at a bug
and in the most deadpans somewhat sad
way say
and that friends is how we deal with
insects was the most beautiful
undermining of
all the reverence that might have been
forming around a character whose
abilities are grounded in this cultural
ritual
it's so rich you all the other
culturally relevant to me anyway and
beautiful moment was the one in which
kilwa's sibling
which is where i'm confused because they
wear clothes that are stereotypically
feminine
but i'm told they're masked i don't know
so they them is is
gonna be their pronouns until they
describe themselves
regardless the cultural implications of
someone using origami as a communication
device as a way to paper cut
and destroy things this beautiful art
form of destruction
reminds me of the haiku guy way way back
and i am
very here for it the other members of
the troop showing their abilities is
refreshingly new
in this arc more than the others i feel
as though we're seeing how individual
characters shine and what they can do
and how they navigate the unknown if
anything they're the opposite to gone
and keela they're entirely flexible and
it's that level of mastery that the two
are going to need for that big fight i
just realized we
jumped cut away from it's been a week i
think the most important thing to
remember about this episode is that the
phantom troopers
fighting to save their home from ants
they're invested
and so they will fight hard but notably
they're not fighting the strongest ants
the ants still have the upper hand
i guess they have hands not claws i
don't know what what
you put in the comments what do ants
have
at the end of their arms legs arms legs
slums either way there's a higher and
that's what i'm hoping we return to when
we get into episode 97
episode 97 and it seems we're sticking
with the phantom troop for this week i
suppose
listening to the narrator introduction i
can see a way that the ants could be
defeated and it doesn't actually include
any of the other protagonists or
antagonists it's just them
their pride is so powerful that they
will likely just fight to their death
amongst themselves or they could the
rest of them will get a star or planet
thrown at them
it's kind of interesting how the main
destruction of the ants in these
episodes sort of
mirror the behavior of kids killing bugs
and maybe that's a metaphor for
you know the phantom troop last episode
one was crushed and this episode a sun
was shot on it like
having a magnifying glass on a sunny day
phantom troop
they like to play they're like a circus
troupe
but fan to me their behavior is
metaphorically dark and kind of mean but
they're also trying to save people which
you know really wasn't so accurate when
you think about it because they weren't
trying to save people i suppose by the
end
what's his face egyptian god helmet dude
mocked their begging to be killed and it
was a moment that reminded us that
these people for all their doing a good
thing that kind of help society
they're not good people which it might
have been possible to forget in the
context of how objectively bad the king
and zazen are there's a lot more
complexity
in all of these villains and so it's
very difficult to say
who is a villain who's a hero what's a
protagonist and what's an antagonist in
a world where
you can kind of see both perspectives
quite balancedly
balancedly speaking of zazen it was
interesting to consider that she decided
to build a castle that has the same sort
of form factor as her mother's
despite being scornful of the queen ant
she took after her in a lot of ways
and then we have vacuum kid who slipped
out of spider guys anal leakage to
bounce entirely unrealistically before
our very
eyes boob physics shouldn't be something
i need to discuss in a serious review
but here we are i guess
boobies and the reason i can say anal
leakage
because he says something similar that
spider with his pulsating butthole that
shoots white fluid i mean come
on takashi i am sorry if you were eating
breakfast or dinner while watching this
but i can't get it out of my head and
i just twitch out with the twitching
i was eating yogurt while watching this
episode so you're not alone
just a note it didn't stop me it's
surprisingly difficult to stop me eating
by grossing me out but it was still
gross
takashi clearly realized once he'd
finished animating spider guy's death
that the spider could have literally
used his webbing to stop the blood from
being drained from his body
oh tagashi that kind of meta discussion
is always entertaining to hear tagashi
talk about
through the characters voices i also
would like you to consider the physics
of quick changing out of a pair of jeans
and a t-shirt but i'm not going to talk
about it i just want you to consider it
because i want to talk about kaluto
whose musical refrains have very much
been the zoldic theme
rather than dipping into the phantom
troop one it happened last episode and i
didn't mention it but now i'm going to
because it was an early indication of
the fact that kaluto hasn't joined the
troop to actually be a member but to do
a task for the family
i assume they're trying to get to
kilowatt and the best way to do that is
to hang around the troop because they'll
turn up near each other eventually which
is a very smart way of doing things
actually usually
if you have two sets of characters that
are in different locations
just join one of them and they'll end up
in the same place it's like kaluto
sitting out here with me
watching the meta of the show and then
goes huh i can do something with that
it's either that
or kaluto is trying to deliberately
infiltrate the troop for another reason
and i'm not sure what's going on there
but it was cute to see kilwa's creepy
assassinate do actually run in the
family with the
deep purple stare kaluto gave followed
by the stare of dejection that the
trooper all remarkably strong
something that we've all had to take a
hard look at because
you know strength numbers aren't
provided the strength of an individual
character is
entirely almost entirely dependent on
how the other person interacts with them
emotionally
and that's been a thread throughout the
series but seeing you know
dark scarfed guy turn into
even darker guy before switching on a
sun
was a true highlight i need to learn the
names of the troop i've just realized
but
it's too late now i'm not gonna start
and these ability names know your place
unforgiven burnt by the sun they're also
final and so judgmental
whatever he turned into it was
definitely something that the others had
seen and knew he would win with if it
came to it they knew he was gonna win
being told that they could be the
interim leader if they found and killed
the queen first was absolutely a joke
for kaluto at that point because
they must have known what would happen
then again they wanted kaluto to prove
themselves didn't they not dying is very
much proof
and the problem here is that now there's
another loose end
someone else who's looking for killah
always cuba last arc it was piggy
now it's another sibling how is killer
supposed to catch a break i don't really
think he actually ever could
and things are about to get even more
difficult but because i haven't seen how
i can't comment any further so that's it
from me
if you enjoyed this rambling booty walk
through a queen's castle click here here
and here don't forget to like subscribe
share click the bell go get something to
eat and i'll see you next time